لا تزال قضيه تسريب وثائق امريكيه فائقه
السريه تتفاعل في واشنطن والعديد من عواصم
الدول الحليفه بدا البنسه وزاره العدل
الامريكيه التحقيق في تسريب هذه الوثائق
المتعلقه بالنزاع في اوكرانيا والتقييمات
الامريكيه لحاله القوات الاوكرانيه
والاوضاع الميدانيه بشكل عام
تناوله روبيه
بشان اوكرانيا نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان
تقيمات الامريكيه العائده الى فبراير شباط
الماضي حضرت مما سمته فجوات في حج القوات
الاوكرانيه وامدادها وارجح حتى تقييمات
الاستخبارات الامريكيه اي اديه هجوم
الربيع المرتقب من الجانب الاوكراني الى
مكاسب محدوده على الارض وفقا للواشنطن
وذكرت الصحيفه وفقا للوثيقه المسربه ان
استراتيجيه تكييف التمحور حول استعاره
المناطق على المحور الشرقي والتقدم لقطع
الممر البريه المؤدي الى شبه جزيره القرم
رجحت الوثيقه ان قوه دفاعات الروسيه
وانخفاض تزويد القوات الاوكرانيه بالذخيره
قد تزيد الخسائر اثناء الهجوم
وفي واشنطن قالوا منسقه الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القوميه
الامريكي جون كيربي ان المسؤولين
الامريكيين تواصلوا مع حلفائهم على
مستويات الرفيعه بشان الوثائق المسربه عبر
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي وفي تصريحات خلال
لقائه الدوري بوسائل الاعلام اضاف كيربي
ان وكالات حكوميه تجري مراجعه لاي تداعيات
لتسريب هذه الوثائق على الامن القومي
الامريكي
على الشعب الامريكي ان يدرك اننا نتعامل
مع هذا الامر بجديه بالغه فقد تم اطلاع
الرئيس عليه كما ان وزاره الدفاع تقود
جهدا مشتركا مع وكالات حكوميه لمراجعه اي
تداعيات على الامن القومي جراء هذا
التسريب فيما تقود وزاره العدل تحقيقا في
هذا الموضوع ليس هناك اي عذر لان تكون هذه
الوثائق في المجال العام ويجب حمايتها
وسيتم اتخاذ اجراءات بعد معرفه ما حدث
المسؤولون الامريكيون تواصلوا مع الحلفاء
والشركاء المعنيين بالامر على مستويات
رفيعه